in the first video on evolution I drew  something that I called an ape and then  I drew a tail on it and what I want to  do in this video is clarify that that  was absolutely wrong Apes Apes have no  tails and it's actually one of the main  distinguishing characteristics of Apes  there's obviously other primates that  also have no tails but Apes definitely  have no tails and just to clarify  there's kind of two families within Apes  and they're common names or the lesser  apes and the great apes and the lesser  apes the lesser apes are things like  gibbons lesser apes and the great apes  are things like chimpanzees and gorillas  and and me on human beings so these  right here these are the great apes  these are the great apes and clearly  this great ape right here did not have a  great sense of style in 1994 and and  really didn't feel the need to have a  haircut